Angelica Clute
had been battled over the head with a
table leg she had been gagged
in a restaurant bound a cable ties she'd
been stabbed and she'd been raped
and then she had been dumped under the
floor like a bag of rubbish concealed
underneath the church floor
[Music]
when did you join the police force I
joined the police in 1977 21st of March
1977 it's a date ingrained in my mind
and I was a science technician I was a
senior technician in the school and I
was at the top of a game age 22 and I
joined the police for a challenge I
quickly recognized the CID that's where
I wanted to go wanted to investigate
crime as I progressed I started off as a
constable a uniform constable and then
became a detective Constable I was a
detective Constable working as in the
lower level as part of the team now you
know it's not always when I retired I
was a senior investigating officer it's
not just about me as a senior detective
it's about the team and I was part of
that team load down so I understood the
whole processes all the way through and
as I moved on in the rank I became a
senior investigating officer as a
detective inspector a senior
investigating officer a detective Chief
Inspector more complex investigations
and then ultimately when I left the
police a detective superintendent a
senior officer dealing with very high
profile complex investigations but
everything that you deal with as a
detective you're dealing with
housebreakings you're dealing with
robberies burglaries
great series sexual crimes models
everything and nowadays you know
ultimately a in my later years I was
dealing with terrorist acts the Glasgow
Airport terrorist attack so the variety
in the police is unbelievable
do you remember the most violent crime
scene you've attended our name is Angela
Thompson I always remember the names of
the victims and it was a sunny afternoon
I was a detective inspector we get a
call to go
to a place in a place called Elvin
because there was a girl in the garden
with no head
the boyfriend
Brian Fernley who is now dead he
believes that she was having an affair
with other men
and he cut her head off with a beer
bottle and a close horse
and then ran away with the head this
case didn't really make the media it
made the local media that's a horrendous
case I hear in this case and that's when
it sticks in my mind
but they all do
when you attend something like that and
witness someone in that kind of way how
does it make you feel one thing is is
talked about quite a lot in in
challenging roles that the police in the
military and and medical people is do
they do they become hardened to what
they see
as far as I'm concerned as a detective I
have never become hardened to what I see
because uh you're human
and you can't detach yourself from the
fact that you're looking at a person
that's been killed violently by another
human being
so it's very difficult it's very
difficult you're dealing with what
you're what you're always thinking in
the challenging investigations
particularly the big complicated ones
you know where there's huge media
pressure on on you as a senior
investigating officer yes I can have I
made a mistake is there something else
we can do can we do this again because
you know that whatever you do you make a
decision
police officer the interviews in the
street there the detective Sergeant or
whatever but ultimately the sio
investigating officer makes a decision
you're making a split-second decision
that can be tried and tested at court
people could be spending hours
researching that decision that you made
and say why did you do that Mr Swindle
why did you make that decision and you
keep records policy fires of it things
like that but
everything is sure so fast moving
there's a lot of emotions a lot of
pressure
but
for me
I always look to myself as I take a step
back and I says a calm rational attitude
is there a type of case or a case that
sticks out with you that's had the
biggest effects on you or particularly
heartbreaking
I I think probably one of the big ones
are personal and professional
life-defining
change for me
was the mother of a Polish student
Angelica clerk in her church in Glasgow
in September 2006 by an individual
called Peter Tobin
Angelica clerk was a Polish student that
came to Scotland
to better her education
and to make money to send back to her
family in Poland she stayed in a church
in Glasgow St Patrick's Church in
Glasgow
she disappeared
she completely disappeared one day it
has been dealt with as a local by the
local uniform Chief Inspector backed up
by the local CID
as a missing person inquiry but that
changed as a week went on because what
the local Chief Inspector and the local
CID established was that the last person
she had been with
a person called Patrick McLaughlin the
handyman at the church
Patrick McLaughlin was in fact Peter
Tobin a missing sex offender and that is
when I became involved I was a senior
investigating officer dealing with
various types of complex inquiries and I
get the call from the chief Constable's
office a Friday afternoon that this was
now a high risk missing person Peter
Tobin
had raped and tried to kill two young
girls and haven't near Portsmouth
in the 1990s early 90s
and it was sentenced to prison that's
why he was a sex offender
but it was a registered sex offender and
had gone off the radar so we have a real
concern
missing sex offender using a false name
missing young women
who is she where
is Peter Tobin
how did you know that Pat McLaughlin was
Peter Tobin how did you know that that
was Peter Tobin using an alias when
Angelica went missing it was established
that she had been with the last person
she had been with was the church
handyman called Patrick McLaughlin and
Patrick McLaughlin what for a homeless
charity called the Loaves and Fishes he
actually had a name tag Patrick
McLaughlin what had happened was the
police the local policemen were making
investigations had gone public and they
put that picture out publicly
people came forward you see that's not
Patrick McLaughlin that is Peter Tobin
so we'll arranged for the church to be
searched the church had been searched
before
but the Dynamics and the categorization
had changed there was real concerns for
Angelica so the church was searched
using
team of experts Pulsa police search
advisors and found
under the floor the body of a young
woman
we couldn't see who that was at that
time due to injuries
and the person that was vital to that
was a person Carol Rogers who has
appeared on lead Bible before and Carter
was a scientist
and she told me do not move
the victim body
and she explained why because of the
injuries and because of other body
fluids if the body was moved
it would mean that we could destroy
evidence
so Caro
said okay I'll go under there and take
samples
meanwhile I'm dealing with the huge
impact the media Sky TV live stuff from
the scene
in criticism by Angelica's family why
didn't they find the body is that her
body in there we didn't know at that
time
so all credit to the scientists and that
is one thing I have always said is our
progress through the police
trust your experts and trust your team
and Carol she lay under the floor
and she took samples from the body of a
young woman and with what she found and
what other scientists found we could
piece together what happened
to that young woman it was only a result
of clothing and other things and DNA
ultimately that we identified that that
women under the floor was Angelica click
Angelica kluk
had been battled over the head with a
table leg she had been gagged
in a restaurant bound the cable ties
she'd been stabbed and she'd been raped
and then she had been dumped under the
floor like a bag of rubbish concealed
underneath the church floor
at this point Peter tybin becomes a
suspect how did it come to be that you
arrested him for this crime well there
was various aspects about this
investigation
but you know regarding evidence
regarding forensic evidence
but the big one there was a Manhunt
Peter Tobin's face was flashed all over
national TV
and it was found
in a hospital in London he checked into
Hospital London in a false name
and someone recognized them and that is
how we became involved that's how we
tracked him down and of course when we
start looking at Toby now I decided when
I saw the injuries it caused and the way
they had concealed their body instead of
the scene for a couple of days probably
hoping that she wouldn't be reported
missing
and then something changed the Dynamics
changed it at any left the scene and I
thought in my mind this guy is 60.
you don't get to 16 it's the first time
you've killed in that fashion the
sophistication the violence the crime
scene management really covered up
things like the scene they had moved
their shed where it had taken place it
rebuilt a shed all these things added up
in my mind I thought he has done this
before
and that's when I decided to look at his
life
because I believed it had killed other
people
he was convicted of the mother of
Angelica Clerk in May 2007.
and after he was convicted that is when
we went public with operation anagram
regarding
other potential victims who had been
working in the background but they
couldn't go public
before he was convicted of the mother of
Angelica clerk there had been
stuff with the case and we identified a
that Tobin had been in Bathgate a place
near Edinburgh in 18 1981 and it was the
same time
as a young woman Vicki Hamilton had gone
missing and the police blazing with the
police the head in the police that were
dealing with that missing person they
conducted a full review of that missing
person and the result of that review
they've got forensic evidence that
linked Tobin
to
Vicky Hamilton case
and that also included
searches of the house where he stayed
for the found a dagger the pulse of the
sales advisors teams found a dagger and
on that dagger was DNA and there was a
POS that was belonging to
Vicki Hamilton
and found at a bus station in Edinburgh
and on that bus was DNA
in the DNA
was Peter Tobin's son
there was further inquiries done
relation to throughout the UK
looking at Tobin's life where he was
timelining look at his whole life we did
it in liaison every single head of CID
from throughout the UK was involved
and what they did was reviewed all the
missing people and one came under the
radar for us operation anagram
was a missing ghetto Dana McNichol she
had been at a lip hook
Music Festival
and she had been hitching a lift with
the guy she met that day
and when she was
hitching a lift to get picked up they
get a lift from a guy
a Scottish guy
the person that stopped at a service
station
and the young guy that she was with had
gone into the garage
service station
and waiting he can back out the car was
gone
so Dana was nowhere
money had been used that card had been
used along the Route
along a particular route and also in the
town of Margate
and Margate is where Peter Tobin stayed
at that same time 1990 1991. this didn't
basket
and he stayed in Margate at the same
time we had an arrangement between both
houses
and quieties then one made
locally that house he stayed at in
Margate
and a witness was traced that spoke
about Tobin
it's called them Scottish P nice
Scottish P digging a hole in a back
Garden
with the help of the the head of CID
there at that time then we also
detective superintendent in Essex
because she was from Essex they
conducted I say it's a full
excavation using forensic archaeologists
there are set up specialists first Board
of the found
was actually that of Vicki Hamilton
and I get the phone call and I couldn't
believe that
says it was day never expecting to be
there it was Vicki Hamilton and then
they continued Excavating and found the
body
of Dana McNichol buried
in the back Garden in Graves prepared
Graves deeply down in polythe in the
shooting
it was three separate court cases for
Peter Tobin
did you attend court at any point Peter
Tobin was convicted in May 2007 of the
model of Angelica cloak he was then
convicted after a trial in the day of
the mother of Vicki Hamilton
and then at Chelmsford Court in Essex
the trial
for Dana McNichol I was at that court
trial I was sitting there watching
and they're watching Tobin looking at me
looking at everyone making though it's
laughing feigning illness
absolutely horrendous you get a full
life tariff
Fallout model of dynamic Nicole uh but
to sit there and look at him and share
his behavior there
and he's total content for the victims
uh it's just a horrible guy a horrible
horrible individual that's in total
denial of what he's done Peter Tobin is
like many serial killers
is a controlling individual he's a
cunning individual
and he's a narcissist
he'll speak and he spoke in interviews
he spoke and spoke and spoke
and he spoke about his favorite subject
himself it's like in Brady and all these
other people
it's about control it's about speaking
about themselves
and that's what it was with with Tobin
he's in total denial
of
the Angelica clip mother and then the
other ones that we found the other
victims that we found
I haven't dealt with people like Peter
Tobin and other murderers do you believe
evil exists
there's a big concept round about people
that kill murderers is it nature nurture
or born evil
there are people that are just born evil
but for me it's very difficult as
someone that has dealt with
the victims dealt with the victors
families and seeing a killer to actually
mitigate some of the issues and say it's
a shame that person killed because of
something that happened to their early
childhood
that are progressive things that happen
people something that maybe triggers it
in their early days
but a lot of the killers are just evil
do you think Peter Tobin was evil Peter
Tobin was evil Peter Tobin has killed
other people we don't know who else is
killed he's definitely killed other
people but the fact that it targets
people that were vulnerable at that time
the fact that it can
hang around religious establishments
helping groups the fact it was a very
affable type guy
and the fact that he bury's victims
will
probably never know
who else is killed
Beethoven for me was evil but
all cases kill us
a potential to kill again
but there's different types of models
there's different types of models and
the serial killers are high profile ones
they're cunning
controlling
or conniving
charming and they can be clever
and it's all about power and control the
people like Eden Brady and Myra hindley
Fred and rosemary West
you've got these people at Tobin you've
got these people
it's a challenge for them to see if they
can get away with it
and they all show similar traits about
power
the power of being able to take a life
away
about shortling someone binding them
watching them the victim to the last
press where they can take their ultimate
fantasy that they've got is taking a
life away and there's right through them
all they're all different
but the element there is the power
for them to be able to do it and it's
about control and that is a feature
in the serial killer types but so many
models so many different types of models
sadly so many different types of motives
um there can be the the mother in in the
street a street fight gang fight
drunk
organized cream that all sorts of
different types of other investigations
typing passed away in October 2022.
when you heard that news how did it make
you feel Peter Tobin was a person that
found illness throughout his life he
checked into hospital and false names at
the trials offend illness and said it
was ill and it was taken away to disrupt
the trial and we kept getting
information out there you know
intelligence or media reporting that
Tobin was dying
I never knew what to believe and then in
October last year
I got the call that it was dying and for
me that was a big big thing to hear that
but more so for the families of the
victims
he died taking secrets to the Grave like
Brady like so many of these people they
took secrets to the Grave
and I just
I always hoped that someday you might
reveal what else it's done I mean Fred
and rosemary West who killed
unknown amount of people in in
Cromwell Street in gloucestershire
Rosemary West is still living and always
hope maybe she'll do the right thing and
see what she has done
but I've said it before Brady Tobin
and other Killers Sutcliffe
not dead Secrets I've taken have been
taken to the Grave
when you look back on your career in the
police force how does it make you feel
I look back at my time in the police in
that it's like
I think about everything and I think of
it
how lucky I was
to be involved in working in such
complex investigations and when I uh
left the police I hate to use the word
retired because you know stole this life
after the police I always say
when my phone rings in the middle of the
night it's something to do with the
family member before performing in the
middle of the night and it would be
someone's been murdered there's a dead
body lie in the street that is the life
he lead in the police working 20 hours a
day sleeping in offices all sorts of
stuff
but I look back at it and I see I'm
proud of what I did
[Music]
and eventually got to his his b body and
we took that out the bin and we put him
on the floor and then it's a case of
recovering all the evidence that you can
so you're considering things like hairs
fibers skin flakes all this kind of
Chase evidence or biological evidence